Friday is April fifteenth the deadline
for filing your taxes next on book TV
many unhappy returns the new memoir from
former IRS commissioner Charles Rosati
the program's one hour good evening and
welcome to tonight's meeting of the
Commonwealth Club of California I am Joe
Epstein the past president of the
Commonwealth club's board of governors
and i'll be your chair and moderator for
today we also welcome our listeners on
the radio and the viewers of c-span book
TV and now it is my pleasure to
introduce our distinguished speaker I
thought I'd begin with a very brief
history lesson the office of
Commissioner of the internal revenue
service was created by an act of
congress on july first 1862 the
Commissioner is appointed by the
president with the advice and consent of
the Senate at that time there was no set
tenure and the Commissioner served as
long as the president chose the IRS
restructuring and reform act of nineteen
ninety-eight amended the original act
and said a five-year term of office our
guest tonight former IRS commissioner
and clinton appointee charles Rosati was
commissioner at that time and i am happy
to report that while serving under the
administration's of both president
clinton and george w bush he served out
his complete five-year term which
expired in November 2002 and when
Charles Rosati became commissioner of
the IRS in 1997 it had been reported
that the agency had the largest customer
base and the lowest approval rating of
any public institution in America the
agency was mired in scandal and caught
in political turmoil of major proportion
with management and technological
problems many in fact dismissed the IRS
as a hopelessly flawed enterprise well I
have not painted a very
picture here but as the first business
person to ever hold this position
Charles Rosati has used his perspective
to write a book and the book is titled
many unhappy returns and he will tell us
about it tonight and now about mr.
Rosati Charles Rosati transformed this
much-maligned IRS through strong
leadership in an atmosphere of intense
public scrutiny and he admits that some
of his turnaround strategies were risky
but as a business person he understood
those risks and as important he
understood who his customer was his goal
was to transform the IRS to run like a
21st century business and to overhaul
the agency and reorganize the structure
into separate units he successfully
imparted that message to the over
100,000 employees of the agency who in
turn translated the same message to the
American taxpayers and today many small
business owners as well as over a
hundred and thirty two million
individual taxpayers are the
beneficiaries of those long overdue
reforms in 1970 Charles masada
co-founded American management systems
AMS and for 27 years he served in a
variety of capacities there including
president CEO and chairman of the board
and in 1979 AMS was one of the first
technical service companies to go public
mr. Rosati earned his a B and economics
and was magna [ __ ] laude from Georgetown
University and he received his mba with
high distinction from the Harvard
Business School he received the
distinguished civilian service medal
from the Department of Defense in 2002
and received the Alexander Hamilton
medal from the Department of the
Treasury he also received the alumni of
the year award from Harvard Business
School he serves on many corporate
boards including Merrill Lynch and
company and aes corporation and as a
senior advisor of the carlyle group he
previously addressed the Commonwealth
Club in 1999 while serving as IRS
commissioner so please welcome back to
the Commonwealth Club businessman and
author of the book many unhappy returns
mr. Charles Rosati thank you very much
for that that kind introduction and it
is good to be back and addressed the
Commonwealth Club you were kind enough
to welcome me when things were not so
not looking so good at the IRS in 1999
so I appreciate it as you mentioned i
completed my term as commissioner in
november of 2002 but I I still have
trouble imagining that I actually ended
up taking that job because I was not
planning to leave AMS where I was still
operating as chairman of the board and I
certainly had not dreamed of taking over
a government agency let alone the IRS
but there I was in November of 1997
being sworn in as commissioner and it
was not a normal time for the IRS if
there ever is a normal time for the IRS
people were really really angry at that
point shortly after I arrived there's a
columnist that writes in Washington
called they've buried Red Sea humor
column and he found me a great subject
for his columns many times but right
after I got there he wrote this column
in which he reported in a rather deadpan
fashion that my body had been found
under four tons of brochures that were
labeled your IRS tax payer rights that
was about what passed for a joke at that
point in time and it was true that in
the 90s people were really mad at the
IRS but the troubles didn't start in the
90s as a matter of fact if you go back
for a longer period of time you find it
in the 70s and early 80's things were
rather Placid people didn't love the IRS
but they respected the agency for
collecting the money the government
needed and doing a fairly honest
respectable job but starting in the 80s
things started to go downhill and by the
middle 90s there were so many taxpayer
complaints borean to Congress that by
the time i made my courtesy visits and
my confirmation hearings i found that
most of the members of congress actually
had a full time
staff person that was doing nothing but
fielding complaints for the IRS and
there were a lot of symptoms of the
problems one the most visible ones was
that people were getting Dunning letters
from the IRS and then when they called
in they would get a busy signal as a
matter of fact about two years before i
got there i think the IRS set an
all-time world record for busy signals
because it gave out 400 million busy
signals in one year people also had the
impression that somehow the IRS was
picking on the little guy and letting
the big fat cats get away with it all
these things were symptoms another thing
that happens was that in the early 90s
there was a big technology modernization
program that was launched by 1995 that
program was canceled and I was generally
viewed as a bust that had wasted quote
four billion dollars that kicked off a
Presidential Commission which is
something that happens frequently in
Washington they spent a year studying
the IRS and said the agency needed to be
overhauled from top to bottom and by
summer of nineteen ninety-seven which is
just before I came in the ratings the
ratings of the agency according to
surveys and public opinion polls had
reached an all-time low and that was
before one of the most dramatic events
which was a series of Senate hearing is
that some of you might recall because
they were televised in the fall of
nineteen ninety-seven in which there
were taxpayers getting up and telling
stories about how the IRS was ruining
their lives the press picked up on that
and wrote all kinds of stories as a
matter of fact Newsweek had an entire
cover story devoted to the IRS in which
they concluded that it wasn't isolated
incidents the whole agency they said was
quote a rogue agency that was out of
control and then even President Clinton
weighed in and in fact probably the low
point of the whole thing was when he
gave a radio address on Saturday
presidents give radio addresses mostly
every Saturday he devoted the whole
thing the problems of the IRS and he
concluded by saying that he was quote
outraged by the stories of our citizens
harassed and humiliated by what seemed
to be an unaccountable downright
tone-deaf agency and the next morning I
went on Face the Nation to explain what
was going on at the IRS and there's a
picture of being the book squirt
at that at that event at that point it
was pretty clear there were some
symptoms of problems at the IRS but the
dilemma was that a lot of the observers
of the IRS in Congress and elsewhere
understood there were a lot of problems
but they weren't really convinced that
there was ever going to be any big
changes made in this agency for one
thing it was considered one of the most
entrenched bureaucracies in in the
federal government but even raps more
important than that it did still collect
ninety-five percent of the government's
revenues and even the most vocal critics
were a little nervous about upsetting
that true two trillion dollar a year
revenue stream so that's about the time
I stepped into the mill with dilemma
having had no prior experience in the
tax business when it came out that I was
going to take this job of course most of
my friends a few of them were here said
to me things like you're going to do
what you know is a little hard to
explain why I was doing this but I took
the job because the Treasury secretary
at the time was Bob Rubin a person I got
to respect the great deal and he made
the case that while this was a crisis
and a difficult situation it could be
turned into an opportunity to improve
the way this organization worked which
was an important institution for the for
the country and I bought that argument
and I believe it turned out to be right
it's unfortunate but often true that big
institutions oftentimes don't change
very much until there's a crisis that
forces forces things to change so I but
secretary Rubens argument and I think he
turned out to be right on the other hand
I still do remember what was going
through my mind when I was shaking hands
with him to to sign on for this job and
it was a line from a TV show that
Barbara and I used to watch back in the
70s called Mission Impossible any of you
remember that show at the beginning of
the show after the agent accepted the
mission there was a voice that came on
and the voice said if you are captured
or killed the Secretary will disavow any
knowledge of your existence and I was
shaking hands with the secretary but
fortunately he didn't about eight months
after I took office the administration
and the Congress agreed on a reform bill
for the IRS called a restructuring
Reform Act then it was as everything
having to do with taxes and IRS seems to
be pretty complicated so it had a lot of
provisions in it some of work which
weren't so good but but some of which at
least did give some direction to the
agency and I think importantly it gave
some authority to the management of the
agency to make some changes and that was
the time that kicked off about four more
years the rest of my term of making
major changes in the agency and most of
the things that needed to be done and
we're done would not surprise anyone
that was in a business that was going
undergoing change they were the things
that probably common sense would tell
you or business experience would tell
you you have to do it was not a matter
of thinking up things it was more of
getting them done in the context of this
complicated bureaucracy and the two
trillion dollars a year that had to be
had to be continued to be collected the
types of things that were done included
such things as resetting the goals of
the agency so that we focused on serving
the taxpayers as well as collecting the
tax both of which needed to be brought
into balance reorganizing the agency so
that it was moving from a very
fragmented structure to one that was
organized around serving different
groups of taxpayers and achieving
accountability of management in doing
that and of course updating the
technology or at least beginning to
update the technology which was
extremely out of date and finally very
importantly was updating the strategy of
the organization because one of the
reasons that taxpayers had this feeling
that quote it's picking on the little
guy letting the big guys get away is not
because people deliberately in the IRS
made any such decision but just the
opposite because they had not updated
the way the agency strategy and
enforcement techniques worked for many
years so the world had changed income
distributions had changed business had
changed the IRS was still doing things
the way they did them in the early 80s
now if you look at it by the time I left
and today certainly not all the problems
are fixed there's a lot more work to be
done but by many measures the agency is
in fact performing better and taxpayers
did respond in the fall of two thousand
and one there was a story in the front
page of USA Today which I was able to
chuckle at we had stories almost every
day about the IRS and most of them
weren't occasions for chuckling but this
one was because it was a report of a
customer satisfaction survey that was
done by a survey organization that
surveyed how people felt about different
organizations institutions that they did
business with both in the private and
public sector and it reported that the
customers of the IRS the taxpayers were
more satisfied with what the service
that they received then then the
customers of McDonald's who are eating
hamburgers so from this I did not
conclude that people enjoy paying taxes
more than eating hamburgers but rather
that at least the IRS was doing a
somewhat better job of meeting the
reasonable expectations of people that
it was dealing with which is really what
service is all about so I think one
could say that this is a case where the
American democracy perhaps worked the
way you would like it to work there was
a big puppy public uproar not all the
complaints were right but there was an
efficient uproar there were some laws
passed where some changes made and the
IRS made some changes they perhaps not
perfectly but certainly in the direction
that people wanted and that needed to be
done and that I think is the good news
part of the story and telling how that
change came about is one of the reasons
that I wrote the book unfortunately the
story does not have an entirely happy
ending notwithstanding that part of it
but was positive and that's another
reason that I wrote the book because I
believe that it's now time for the
public to do the same thing it did in
the mid-90s which is to get mad again
only this time not about the IRS but
about the whole tax system because the
IRS is only part of the text system and
while I think it made some progress
I think at the same time in fact over a
longer period of time the tax system has
been going in the opposite direction and
in fact has been deteriorating rather
seriously now there are a lot of
objectionable things about the tax
system but in my book I focused on one
of them that I think is really the most
unfair and it really the most dangerous
aspect of where we're going and that is
the way that it effectively works to
inflict an extra tax on all honest
taxpayers how does that come about well
what has been happening is some very
conflicting trends on the one hand the
tax code has been getting for since 1986
when it was reformed has been getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and more
and more and more complex the economy
has also been getting bigger and more
complex and more globalized and at the
same time the resources and the
authorities of the IRS to administer the
code have been getting smaller and the
net effect of that is there is just an
enormous amount of tax that is not being
collected in fact there's just some new
figures out this week that show it's
over 300 billion dollars a year if you
want to translate that into the average
taxpayer it means that every taxpayer
every honest taxpayer fortunately the
majority is paying at least 15 and
probably more like twenty percent extra
to make up for that gap those Free
Riders if you want to take the tax code
and focus on that for a minute it's it's
really hard to describe how out of
control the tax code is I wanted to make
a point about the tax code at a
congressional hearing so I asked some
tax experts at the IRS to just give me a
number as to how many pages though are
on the tax code and how many pages were
being added and after a couple of weeks
you know I called up these folks again I
said where's my numbers I gotta testify
at this hearing and they came in and
advised me not to cite any number
because they couldn't agree on how many
how many pages that were in the tax code
said we just set off another argument as
I think that makes my point better than
than giving out a number it was not only
how big it is but how fast it was
changing during my five years in office
Congress passed 19 tax bills now each
one of those bills has hundreds
provisions by the time you translate
that into what the average taxpayer see
there was over a hundred new forms and
instructions every year what's the
effect of that well there's two effects
one of them is that an enormous amount
of time and money is bent by honest
taxpayers just trying to maintain
records and fill out tax forms as a
matter of fact if you wanted to quantify
it if you had two million people working
all year round doing nothing but filling
out tax forms it still wouldn't equal
the total number of hours that people in
this country spend it works out to about
120 billion dollars a year where at the
time just just feeding the tax code
system but the worst part of it is that
it provides a wonderful opportunity for
promoters and for some taxpayers to
manipulate the way they report and take
advantage of these complex provisions to
avoid paying what they should so that's
one part of the problem the other part
of the problem has to do with the
resources that are provided to the IRS
you might think well the economy is
getting bigger as an enormous amount
money at stake the tax code is getting
bigger there would be some resources
available to at least try to enforce
compliance with this code you might
think that as a matter of fact when I
talk to my business friends they would
ask me often time well what's the
hardest part of this job and would
always be surprised when I said it's not
running the IRS it's not the technology
all that's a problem but it's trying to
get even a moderately acceptable budget
to administer the tax code you might
think well how could that be so hard you
know why would you have so much trouble
getting a little bit of money to bring
in a lot of money and all I can say is
when the federal budget is involved
business logic doesn't have a lot to do
with it because during ten year a
ten-year period while all these
increases were happening the number of
tax returns was going up and up the
absolute size of the IRS dropped by
fifteen percent in other words not just
percentage terms but actually dropped
and the result of that is by the time I
left office I'm continuing today the IRS
was so diminished in capacity that it's
not able to follow up on even a fraction
of the cases where no
people are seriously not paying their
taxes and I'm talking about people who
are not filing returns at all are hiding
money and offshore accounts are
seriously lying about their income I
often compared it to being a cop
standing in the middle of an
intersection where there are banks on
all four corners and are robbers robbing
all four banks that you can see robbing
them and you have to decide which one
you want to stop Rob catch because the
other three you just waved goodbye to
numerically that's literally where the
IRS is today I mean some people would
say well why do I care you know I don't
let the IRS shrink to nothing that's
fine with me well if you stop to think
about it it isn't the honest taxpayer it
isn't the IRS that loses by this it's
the honest taxpayers would have to make
up the gap you know we've heard of the
death tax and the marriage penalty I'm
throwing up at the honesty tax if you're
honest you pay more at least fifteen or
twenty percent more so by continuing
that status quo we're just leaving this
enormous amount of money and ever
growing amount of money on the table but
that isn't even necessarily the worst
part because what it also is doing is
undermining the attitudes that people
have towards paying tax fortunately in
this country more than eighty percent of
the people even today diligently try to
pay their taxes but what has happened
and there are plenty of promoters out
there explaining to people that
everybody else is doing it you know you
can get away with it too so if you look
at the results of people's attitudes as
expressed in surveys there's about fifty
five percent more people today than
eight years ago who openly say they will
cheat on their taxes as much as they can
get away with and the IRS's information
internally certainly backs up that
they're not just talking through their
hat so at the end of my term I began to
speak up about this broader problem of
the tax system and I've continued to do
that in my book which is really the
second reason I wrote this book because
as I mentioned why in the couple of
sentences ago I do think that if you
look back at what happened in the
mid-90s on the one hand it was a good
story of American democracy working the
public got
angry about some part of what was
happening in the government namely the
way the IRS was working with taxpayers
you know there was a lot of a lot of
heat and maybe a little bit of light but
Congress did pass a law the IRS did
change and some things improved so
that's the optimistic aspect of what I
had to say I think what i'm concluding
from that is now is it's time for the
for the public the taxpayers to rise up
again safe to political leaders we've
got to fix this tax system not just the
IRS we got to fix this tax system so
that's my message for tonight i will
stop there and as i said i really love
to have comments and questions from i
noticed we've got some that are written
I'd be happy to take any more thank you
very much our thanks to Charles besadii
the former commissioner of the Internal
Revenue Service for his comments here
today and we do have a large number of
questions mr. Rosati so we should begin
right away and I'm just wondering if
this piqued interest tonight as a result
of the fact that in just about two weeks
the filing deadline April fifteenth
occurs I know my accountant was at my
home the other night and it was a lot of
fun we really enjoyed it or he enjoyed
it and you will enjoy it when I pay him
you did mention in your prepared remarks
about the complexity it's no secret to
any of us that the filling and the
filing of the forms is complex this
person said that for years the public
has been told that tax simplification is
on the way my personal experience and
that's the experience of the person that
wrote the question and I guess mine as
well my personal experience is that just
the opposite what is really wrong here
well what is wrong is that under both
Republican and Democratic
administrations in both the White House
and in Congress every year they've been
passing tax bills that may or may not
have good motivations but the effect of
them is to add more and more complexity
and how
that work well somebody has an idea for
a credit to encourage this or a subsidy
in effect in the incentive as it's
usually called in the tax code to
encourage that whether it's good things
that people might might support you know
ranging from adopting a child to making
oil out of coal you know I mean those
things that range all over the place in
the tax code and hundreds of them are
passed every year just last October
Congress passed another bill just just
the latest one called it was called the
american jobs creation act it's mostly a
business tax bill if you take the
summary of that bill which is on the
website which you can go get from
Congress the summary is 650 two pages
that's just the summary the description
of it there are hundreds of provisions
in there some of them it may take you
know a couple years really for the
Treasury to brought and figure out what
they are some of them are probably
worthwhile things but one of them I'll
give you an example is and encourage is
is it is a effectively a deduction
special deduction to encourage domestic
manufacturing to encourage people to
make things in the United States for you
if you are business and your
manufacturer United States you get a
lower tax rate to think about that how
do you decide what is something that is
being made something that is being
manufactured versus something that is
not there's there's something in there
called the starbucks footnote which
basically is they didn't want to say
that somebody that's making coffee and a
starbucks is manufacturing and getting
this thing so there's a whole series of
rules that are going to come out
hundreds of pages of rules that are
going to help people to explain whether
you know making a donut or a cup of
coffee is manufacturing i mean literally
it's it's the case that if you make a
bunch of donuts in one place and ship
them to a to a store that's
manufacturing and if you make them one
at a time in a store that's not
manufacturing and i'm not making this up
this is in the bill that was passed last
October there are there are there are
just things like that but that come in
every year and some of them may be
well-intentioned some of them may be
just things where Congress is responding
to lobbyists but the effect of this year
after year is you have something that's
completely out of control and that's
what it is okay thank you will I be very
surprised if you weren't anticipating
question on the flat tax the
Commonwealth Club has had a frequent
speaker here presidential candidate and
publisher steve forbes and he's been a
frequent advocate and still advocates i
believe a flat tax and we've had several
questions that fit within this category
is this desirable at all in some form
and can it be as straightforward and
equitable as steve forbes says and
others claim that it could be well i
think that almost everybody that's
looked at or had anything to do with
studying the tax system you know whether
it's economists or theory or
practitioners or anybody thinks that the
basic right idea is to have a system
which has a lot fewer exceptions and
that means you can have lower rates
whether it's one rate or two rates or
whatever it is it boils down to the fact
you tax things pretty much in a simple
straightforward way and that means would
have fewer exceptions to bring in the
same amount of revenue you can have
lower rates in that sense I think
there's pretty broad agreement that
that's a general direction to go there's
a lot of variations there's a lot of
variations as to how that can work the
only time there was actually a tax
simplification of that was really
serious in the last fifty years was in
1986 when President Reagan and some some
of the Democrats in Congress actually
did something like that it didn't go as
far as the total flat packs but it made
the system a lot broader it taxed you
know the tax base became broader there
were fewer exceptions the top tax rate
went down to twenty-eight percent I
think there were only I think three
brackets or something like that at the
time but what's happened in the 20 years
since then is there's been well and
during my five years the congress passed
an average of four tax bills per year
every year that happens and it's gone
completely in the opposite direction
from where it was even in 1986 so the
solution does lie in the direction i
think most people agree of making it
broader with fewer exceptions and have
fewer rates or lower rates whether it's
one rate or you know a couple of rates
is something you get debate well this
next question is
I almost hesitate to ask it because it's
so broad so if if you can define it in a
way that doesn't cover the entire aspect
of it but it has to do with the position
of the Internal Revenue Service on
international taxation I know there's
issues between the state's severe issues
of Taxation and who gets what when
there's interstate commerce but how
about American companies doing business
overseas huh you know how should that be
taxed and do you feel that the IRS and
the American taxpayer gets his fair
share of those yeah well first of all I
do have to point out it's not the IRS
that sets the tax code including on
international tax so but it is a very
important question and it is one of the
areas where things are most out of
control actually because and it's really
a complicated area but effectively the
the u.s. system for for businesses that
operate in a global basis it tries to in
some sense tax their worldwide income
but then it has exceptions of all sorts
for the third deferral of taxes that are
earned abroad and that that whole area
has gotten more and more complex and
more and more subject to manipulation as
the nature of business has become more
global but also has changed from a pure
product economy to one that is based a
lot on intellectual property and
financial services so for example if
you're just moving a piece of a bushel
of something across a border that's
pretty simple to understand but when
you're moving something like that has a
high intellectual content such as
pharmaceuticals software insurance any
of these kinds of things it's it's it's
it's much easier to manipulate where
that income is earned and to thereby in
fact artificially lower the amount of
taxes you pay you can also get into
enormous arguments and do get into
enormous arguments about what the
transfer prices are when when within a
given company a product to ship from one
subsidiary to another and then that of
course helps to determine how
that in current income is earned in a
foreign country versus how much is in
earned in the United States all of those
areas are areas which are a really in
dire need of reform thank you for that
very excellent answer to a difficult
question I'd like to remind you that
you're listening to the Commonwealth
Club of California's radio program and
our speaker today is former commissioner
of the Internal Revenue Service Charles
Rosati it was discussing how to reform
the IRS it would seem to me and I'm
going to put my own title on this
question that the IRS should be funded
in order to do its audits because it's
an investment in creating revenue for
the United States so if you're
short-handed as short-handed as you say
why can't you make that argument to
Congress that by investing money and
increasing the staff of the IRS to do
audits that it will be a payback
many-fold for the country well all I can
say is I tried it isn't by the way only
to Congress because actually it first
has to get through the executive branch
budget in the office of management
budget and actually this is something
that was not obvious the most people but
the during my five years at least the
Congress actually passed more than
ninety nine percent of what was
requested in the executive branch budget
that was submitted by OMB so they cut it
a little bit but not a lot okay the real
problem was getting it into the into the
executive branch budget in the first
place and all I can say is that I did my
best and was completely unsuccessful in
making that argument for five years now
why is it I mean the best answer I can
give you is I it's the give you an
example I once went to a town hall
meeting with a congressman it was a
friendly Congress when he was actually a
supporter of what we were trying to do
and you know he asked me to go out as
sometimes people would do and talk to
some of his constituents about what was
going on in taxes and so forth and
surprisingly a person in the audience
got up and sort of made that point I
said why don't you up because he knew he
claimed that he knew of people in his
unity in his business colleagues that
weren't paying their taxes and he
thought that was really bad because he
was paying his taxes so why he said to
this congressman don't you provide more
money to hire some more IRS agents so so
they can go out and collect this taxes
there isn't it isn't being collected the
congressman said I can I do that he says
I haven't even been able to vote enough
money in the budget to hire you know the
park ranger is to maintain the park so
how can I vote for money to hire IRS
agents what I'm not hiring Park Rangers
now there's a certain there's a certain
logic to that until you really stop to
analyze you know what what's really
going on because the park rangers are
not bringing in the money to fund the
park rangers where the IRS people are
but that political logic unfortunately
has carried the day for about the last
ten years and until somebody steps up
and at a and really provide some
leadership to change that I'm afraid
it's not going to change by the way it's
not just for hiring auditors and agents
I mean it's also I mean there's a lot
that could be done with technology in
the IRS and we did make a lot of
progress while I was there to improve it
but there's much much more that can be
done and it's really that has even a
higher return than hiring more agents
but there's very very little money
available to modernize the technology
all right and here's a good follow-up
just handed to me how much revenue per
hour does an IRS auditor have to make in
order to break even well you know that's
if you just want to look at it on
average the IRS brings in about 50
billion dollars in just actual
enforcement revenue and its budget is
about 10 billion that however is not
really a good way to look at it because
if you just looked at it that way at
what you could do and the most efficient
per hour you'd be a lot more efficient
just sending notices out to your
grandmother for a hundred dollars where
the interest that she didn't pay because
when she gets that IRS no she's probably
going to send in the hundred bucks and
what what it is so that's really cheap
but you wouldn't be doing is going out
and spending three years investigating
people that are hiding money offshore
you know in a tax haven because that
takes a lot more time and it doesn't
necessarily directly bring
and as much direct revenue what it does
do hopefully if you do it enough is and
you put some of those folks in jail it
does provide a deterrent for other
people to do the same thing so you have
to be a little careful about just
looking at it on a dollars per hour
basis but having said that on you do
bring in a lot more money than it costs
just even on the direct direct
enforcement revenues you know people
have said in the past you know what is
in the Commonwealth Club have a
microphone here so you know you can
stand up to the microphone and ask you a
question but we've always stayed with
the card system and here's a reason why
for example there's been a lot of
questions on audits you know the
candidness of not being looked at in
person by some people who come to the
podium here is very good what's the
number one item that triggers an IRS
audit well I don't know whether I really
ought to answer that you know this is a
little bit mysterious but you know I
think I think it doesn't need to be
basically what what the RS tried to do
and of course it's formulas i mentioned
we're very obsolete but on individual
tax returns what it tries to do is based
on past experience do a sort of a
statistical scoring system to look at
what is the probability that that
something is wrong on this particular
return and it could be too many
deductions or it could be something that
indicates there might be some missing
missing income now that's not the only
way it can be done there's also other
data sources that can be used to try to
triangulate in and see whether somebody
might be under reporting their income
but basically it's it's it's it's what
you would think it is it's trying to use
computer techniques and other techniques
to look at the data that you have about
an individual return and assess whether
it's worth auditing because there's a
likelihood that there's something wrong
with that return so if you've never been
audited what should you expect be happy
be happy if you've never been what oh
you mean if you have never been ordered
it now you're going to be or now you're
going to be on well I think the first
thing to recognize is that that an audit
is not does not you know in any way
imply that you that somebody's done
something wrong it's just a check it's a
check of your return
learn to determine whether it's accurate
and you know the the purpose of an audit
is simply limited to that so the the
agent will have some issues as they call
them to look into about whether that
return was was was reported correctly
and we'll try to run through those
issues and usually it involves getting
some documentation together to support
whatever whatever your position was that
was taken on those returns but it is
important to recognize that it does not
imply just the fact that you were
returned was selected for audit that you
did something wrong it's just it's just
a way of checking on whether that return
was accurate or not this is maybe a
question with a political base to it but
it's it reads as follows under the
Clinton years the country built up quite
a large surplus several trillions but
under President Bush's term that trend
has been reversed is there more pressure
on the Internal Revenue Service to
collect unpaid tax obligations when the
country is running a deficit such as we
are now well I think there's a set
there's there's a maybe a little bit
more sensitivity about about the issue
but you know frankly I wish there were
some more concern about it because if
there were enough concern maybe we do
something about the tax code and about
about the resources for the IRS well I
think there must be some CPAs in the
audience because it appears to me that
this may be came from one of them is it
practical to say for example if you earn
over a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year just to pick a random
threshold is it practical to do your own
taxes or with that kind of income might
one miss deductions and write off
opportunities that are available by not
hiring a tax professional well I can
just give you the statistics about sixty
percent of the people individuals that
file returns use a paid preparer to help
them do their returns now if you look at
which people tend to use them more most
people that have
isn't this income in other words they
own a business or they have some
self-employment income it gets more
complicated in those areas and almost i
would say eighty to ninety percent if
not more people that have business
income use use preparers if if if
someone on the other hand has only for
example wages and maybe some dividends
or interest that is you reported on a
1099 form and and then not too many
other complications many of those people
do do their own their own taxes but i
have to say there is the there are so
many various kinds of credits and
savings plans and other kinds of
potential breaks in the code that you
have to be pretty diligent to go through
all those things to to make sure you've
gotten the ones that that are entitled
to tax software has made that a little
bit easier because a lot of people now
do use personal you know tax software to
prepare their returns and they do some
of the better programs ask you a series
of questions that walk you through the
various kinds of deductions and
exemptions that you're entitled to so
that makes it a little bit easier but it
is complicated for people especially if
they have several different sources of
income including business income there's
a follow-up question i believe that the
the turtle Revenue Service refers to
complex tax shelters as abusive tax
shelters is that that's a term that's
generally used yet so this question then
fits in with that how much of the
Internal Revenue Service shortfall which
again you have to help me with the
definition is I think that's the
difference between what is owed and what
is collected it's it's the difference
between what should be paid if everybody
paid what they were supposed to under
the law yes okay it's sometimes
popularly referred to as the tax gap so
how much of this shortfall then is a
result of the various interpretations of
what is allowable and what is not
allowable under the various tax shelter
schemes that are available particularly
to high-net-worth individuals well I
don't have I don't I don't know what
that number is I've been at four to use
I don't know but I will say it's one of
the love the total I'll use just a round
number here
are perhaps 300 billion dollars a year
that's that's a conservative number in
the sense that if it's anything it's
higher than that that is the difference
between what should be paid and what is
paid the kind of tax shelters or abusive
shelters you're talking about which are
primarily used by large corporations and
very very wealthy individuals those are
a major percentage of that it's not by
any means all of it but they are
probably the largest single or one of
the largest single elements in that
three hundred billion dollars right okay
tax estimates federal tax estimates in
California I don't know about other
states there's not only a federal tax
estimate but there's a state tax
estimate do you think the federal income
tax estimate payments will ever go the
way of the Model T car well I doubt it
unfortunately I did it because if people
are are not having enough money withheld
from their taxes where they have income
where there is no withholding you know
in order to keep up on a current basis I
think all the tax code that meant most
of the states as well as the federal
government do require people to make
quarterly payments and it is it is a bit
of a burden but that's that's probably
not one of those things that's going to
go away change the subject just for a
second militia groups that think that
they don't have to pay taxes and the
taxes are illegal how proactive is the
IRS in dealing with anti-government and
anti-tax militia groups that don't pay
their taxes and don't feel the
government has the right to collect them
yeah I think that they're generally
called tax protesters and what they are
people that that have a variety of
theories as to why they don't know any
tax all of which are bogus completely
bogus and been overruled by the courts
many many times and some of them are are
pretty funny they come up with all kinds
of theories that you know the sixteenth
Amendment of the Constitution was never
properly ratified because Ohio wasn't
really a state when the men was passed I
mean I can go on and on
things but they are a serious problem
and the IRS does have resources targeted
against those those people that don't
file returns and don't pay but again
it's a resource problem there are quite
a number I don't have a number to give
you but there this is not a handful of
people this is not like 10 or 20
nutcases out there these are these are
large numbers of people spread actually
surprisingly around various parts of the
country and it's quite resource
intensive to go out and investigate
investigate people in those categories
so while I think the IRS has done a
better job than perhaps it used to at at
putting resources to that problem it
comes right back to the issue that there
aren't enough resources to go around so
there are a lot of people that that
pursue that kind of a kind of activity
that are that are still doing it it's
time for another reminder to our radio
audience you're listening to the
Commonwealth Club of California's radio
program and our speaker today is former
commissioner of the Internal Revenue
Service Charles Rosati he's discussing
how to reform the IRS I think I could
describe the next question or two also
with a political background the Clinton
administration has had its share of
scandals many of which were purported to
be pursued from the right wing but did
President Clinton then retaliate by
encouraging the IRS to single out
Clinton opponents to be audited by your
agency this was a claim according to the
questioner that was made by judicial
watch the public interest group that
investigates public corruption that
there have been allegations of that kind
made over the years many many times and
they continued under different
administrations they continued during
during my period in office and as part
of the reforms that go back actually
before the 1998 act but but especially
they were strength of the 19
there are some very very stringent
safeguards against those kinds of
activities as a matter of fact one of
them is that there is an investigative
agency in the treasury department that
has a thousand a staff of a thousand
people it's called the treasury
inspector general for tax administration
and the it's not part of the IRS it's
part of the Treasury Department and the
only mission of that organization of a
thousand people is to investigate the
IRS so you have a hundred thousand
people in the IRS and you have a
thousand people investigating them in
case there's any allegations and they
are very very rigorous in their
investigations if there's any allegation
of any sort by a taxpayer by an employee
by any member of the public they are
followed up on thoroughly during my term
there were many such allegations they
were all followed up on and I can tell
you that that there is no substance to
any of that in fact one of the best
things even before I got there long
before i got there that has happened as
a result of problems going back to the
50s is that over time there have been
more and more these safeguards put in so
that the one problem that we don't have
in this country is politically directed
audits well here's a follow-up about
politically directed audits and it might
be judicial watch as well that said how
about the audits of the National Rifle
Association the National Review fox news
host Bill O'Reilly well I mean I'm not
going to talk about any specific audit
but I can tell you that that the process
of selecting selecting any return or any
individual for what it is based on an
extremely rigorous process and any
attempt by anybody outside the agency to
influence that process would be subject
to so many investigations and would be
reported so quickly that that your head
would spin as a matter of fact there's a
in the 1998 while they put a specific
provision in that basically requires any
employee of the IRS any employee of the
IRS that who believes that there has
been any communication of any sort from
anyone outside the
ress in the executive branch along the
lines of directly an audit that they
have to immediately report it to about
four different places including the
inspector general the Ways and Means
Committee and and a number of other
places so I can I spent five years there
I had never been there before whenever
the way these allegations I reviewed
those reports very very carefully with
the inspector general and others and
without exception they were found to be
baseless now sometimes if an
organization is or a person is audited
that might have a political profile
people will make that allegation but the
fact that they were audited and they
were a high political profile does not
mean that they were selected for an
audit because they had a high political
profile it means they had something that
they needed to be audited about we've
had several questions that I've put them
all together at a very brief response
here on outsourcing can and does the IRS
use outsourcing as a way to save money
should it use it more frequently if it
actually does and as there are
opportunities to do more of it I mean
they're not they're not enormous
opportunities where you can take the
whole agency and outsource it because
most of what the IRS does is is deal
with taxpayers taxes and that's
something that is widely viewed to be
something that needs to be done as a
governmental function but there are
there are a number of things that are
outsourced a lot of the technology
almost all the technology development is
outsourced there are various kinds of
support functions that are being
considered for outsourcing and in fact
there's an initiative throughout the
federal government to look at what's
called competitive sourcing to try to
look at anything that can be competed to
to have that done so that is a tool that
can be used and it is being used at the
conclusion of your term in 2002 how much
more if any management control and
authority did you have compared to 1997
when you first took the job well I think
in terms of legal authority and what's
on on the books the IRS commissioner has
a significant amount authority to run
the agency has no authority on
tax code but he has a significant
whoever's office does have a significant
amount of authority operating within
some rules and constraints but does have
a significant amount of authority what
what is what I think is more important
is because of many of the changes that
we were able to make and that were
facilitated by the 1998 act the internal
structure of the agency and the way that
it was organized and set up made it much
more practical to actually exercise that
authority and especially to exercise it
to do things like change the enforcement
strategy for example oh and just to give
you a simple example in the in the way
that the agency was set up in the part
at the time I got there which was a
legacy of years of changes back through
the 50s it was essentially like having
43 different IRS's because there were
districts and other kinds of units that
each had managers in charge and they
essentially ran things the way that they
way they thought saw fit in those in
those areas so the headquarters could
give out directives but then each each
unit would sort of interpret them
whatever way they wanted to and even on
things like technology everybody was
buying their own different standards of
technology so it was like having a
Museum of Technology each each each
example that had ever been produced over
the previous 40 years existed somewhere
in the IRS that was not an efficient way
to exercise authority or even just to
get things done so as a result of the
reorganization and some other changes
the agency is in a better position to
have a unified strategy and to actually
execute on its plans and it's using that
authority under the current Commissioner
as well as while I was there well mr.
Rosati one of the highest visibility
issues that President Bush is putting
forth is about the reform of Social
Security and can you comment and what
role the IRS would play should there be
additional taxes withheld from employees
paychecks to help fund it what is your
feeling on that I actually don't know I
don't think there's been a purple and
proposed the IRS does collect the fight
guys it's called the social security
taxes it does have it is the agency that
does that so to be
extent that there would be a change in
the rules for for collecting or paying
those taxes it would be the IRS I
presume that would have the job of
administering that but I don't know at
least I'm not aware of that there's been
any details laid out on how that would
work there's been several questions also
on offshore shelters I think one of the
news items that I'm familiar with is the
repatriation aspect by corporations of
bringing money back to this country from
the Cayman Islands and other areas
whether these shelters exist could you
just generally or says specific as you'd
like to be sir talk about offshore
shelters are some of them considered
criminal and if so what makes them
criminal vs. acknowledged and legal
shelters well that is actually a very
good question a very complex question
but just to try to simplify it there's
there's there's some of what was in
there that he was talking about repay
she and it isn't a shelter at all it's
just part of the tax code it just says
that if a u.s. corporation earns income
in a foreign country it does not get
taxed don't have to actually pay the
cash tax on that in most cases in
something in a lot of cases until it
actually brings the cash back that
that's just the way the tax code is set
up and so just talking about
repatriation is not a tax shelter what
does a tax shelter is finding ways to
manipulate the income of an individual
or a business to make it appear that
that income is earned in a someplace
that is a tax shelter that whether it's
the Cayman Island a tax haven where it's
the Cayman Islands or anywhere else so
that it appears that the income is
earned their and therefore the tax is
not paid and as long as the cash isn't
brought back it stays there so that can
be a tax shelter and then third one that
you mentioned what with respect to
criminal issues has to do with something
entirely different it's not involved in
trying to you know subtly shade where
you earn your income it's just hiding it
so for example there was a newspaper
report a couple of weeks ago about a
case that the IRS brought a criminal
case in court against an individual who
was a entrepreneur in the
telecommunications industry who was
accused of hiding
450 million dollars of capital gains
income just flat hiding it you know
offshore places no pretense of shelters
just just putting it there and not and
not paying tax on it that is obviously a
criminal if proven it would be a
criminal a criminal offense i do want to
point out that that made story because
it was 450 million dollars of income it
was hidden and so in that sense that was
an unusual case because there aren't
that many people that have 450 million
dollars to hide but what he was doing
was not unusual there are hundreds of
thousands of people doing the same thing
flat hiding money in you know offshore
places there's a question here about a
book by david johnston I think it's
David Cay Johnston who was the New York
Times reporter I'm familiar with the
book yes I am what is your opinion and
your reaction to this book entitled
perfectly legal well what what what mr.
Johnston has done he's a New York Times
reporter that covers taxes in the IRS is
he's laid out in a you know fairly
thorough fashion a litany of some of the
schemes that people have used to reduce
income except he is focused on his title
perfectly legal I'm things that are at
least color ibly or arguably legal under
the tax code so he's arguing essentially
the case of how manipulable the tax code
currently is which of course is one of
the points I made in my presentation
that because of the complexity that the
tax code it allows for this kind of
manipulation so if you want to have an
exhaustive list of how some of these
things can be done read mr. Johnston
book thank you sir are you concerned
that the results of corporate research
credits are often exported as part of
offshoring oh I don't know I think I'll
duck that when I'm not sure I know the
answer to that after your 5 years at the
Internal Revenue Service would you like
to tackle another government agency
that's an easy one no I did it once
that's that's once in a lifetime this
questioner States and this is kind of
discouraging
if it's true I have no reason to believe
it's not it says many of the changes in
the IRS implemented under your watch
have been reversed please explain your
stance and your feelings about this
taxation without representation as
tyranny well I I just don't agree with
the implication I don't think they've
been reversed i think my successor whose
name is Mark Everson has done an
excellent job of building on what we did
he's taken the reorganized the agency
and some of the new technology and he's
using it he's also doing a very vigorous
job of trying to do what we started
which was the direct the enforcement
resources against the real abusers of
the system as opposed to just giving out
traffic tickets to people with a minor
problem I agree with that entirely so I
don't agree with that implication of
that question well mr. Rosati
unfortunately we've reached the point in
our program where there's time for only
one last question and I'm going to go
back to a category of questioning that
we did at the beginning regarding audits
and it says what's the most common
cheating that people do on their taxes
and I guess they're talking about
individuals well I think I think I've
answered that once before I don't think
I want to give a specific answer the
most common one but generically I mean
there are people to take deductions
they're not entitled to there are people
leave out income that they should be
reporting and there are people that you
know use devices to generate losses to
offset gains that they had which they
really weren't entitled to those are the
kind of things well some of these some
of these losses are are either shelters
or schemes if you will that have been
established maybe by the accountants and
the attorneys that people hire if if
that's the case should there be a
governmental action against the
accountants and the attorneys as opposed
to the taxpayers and there has been that
was one of the things that we started
and my term was to initiate audits of
promoters of tax shelters and that has
been continued vigorously and there been
some very significant cases brought
against promoters some of whom were
accounting firm some of whom were law
firms some of whom were other
kinds of tax promoters our thanks to
Charles Rosati former commissioner the
Internal Revenue Service and author of
the book many unhappy returns for
joining us today and we also thank our
audiences here and on radio and on
television and now this meeting of the
Commonwealth Club of California
celebrating over a hundred years of
enlightened discussion is adjourned mr.
Rosati will sign books right here and if
you have one please line up right in the
center here Charles Rosati served as IRS
commissioner from 1997 to 2002 he's
currently a senior advisor for the
carlyle group in Washington DC many
unhappy returns is published by harvard
business school press on the web at HBS
press dot org